If you don't like your accent and
have spent time trying to modify it
and change it to resemble an
anglophone accent,
then this video is for you.
In today's video, we're diving
straight in with some stats
as to why you should
embrace your accent.
If you haven't seen Episode One,
then go ahead and watch it with
the link up here and then make
sure you come right back.
Why should you embrace your accent
when you speak in English?
Reason Number 3: Because most
English speakers in the world
don't have an Anglophone accent.
Let me give you a quick maths
and history lesson.
According to the 2021 edition of
Ethnologue: Languages of the World,
there are 978.2 million people
across the globe
who speak English
as a second language.
That's compared to 369.9 million for
whom English is their mother tongue.
In other words, more English speakers
don't have a native accent
than those that do. Thank you
and good night.
I'm going to keep those numbers
up on screen so they really sink in.
Number of people who speak English
as a second language: 978.2 million.
Number of people who speak English as
their mother tongue: 369.9 million.
That's 264% more people who speak
English as a second language.
Put another way, for every one person
who speaks English as their
mother tongue, 2.6 people speak
English as their second language.
You get the point. Unless you
live in an anglophone country,
it's likely that most of the people
you interact with will have
a non-anglophone accent. So
embrace your accent.
Reason Number 4: Embracing your
accent will show your employer
that you are a hard worker. We
covered this in episode one,
so I'm not going to repeat
the whole point again,
but learning a second
language is hard work.
Don't hide the fact that
you've put that work in.
It's important to note that most
jobs will not require you to
have an anglophone accent when
you're speaking.
Usually, employers prioritise fluency
and confidence when speaking
in English over a particular accent.
I would strongly suggest that
you spend your time developing your
confidence and your fluency
when speaking in English rather
than trying to modify and change
your accent to resemble an
anglophone accent. It takes a lot
of time to change the way you speak.
Ask any speech therapist.
Spend that time on strengthening
other skills. This is a really
important subject because it's
something that a lot of people
worry about. So we've written
a whole blog post on the subject
of embracing your accent. So do
me a favour. Go and read it,
then embrace your accent. Stop worrying
about it and start spending
your time on the other core
English language skills.
That's everything for our embracing
your accent series. If you
want to see more videos like this
then make sure you subscribe.
We have videos coming out to help
you with Business English,
and in the meantime, embrace
your accent, embrace its tones,
embrace its textures, and I
will see you next time. Bye